What Sherlock Holmes reconstructs in his reasoning over here
is a cause-effect chain.
First, Dr. Watson ran across mud;
therefore, the servant had to clean the shoe.
And therefore there were scratches found in the shoe.
In debugging, we also have such a cause-effect chain:
from the defect to the infection--that is, an error in the state--
and finally to the failure,
which can be observed by a user.
The difference in the Sherlock Holmes story, however,
is that Sherlock makes just one observation
and deduces everything that must have happened before;
whereas in debugging, so far, we have assumed that we can actually observe
what has happened before in the way we assume
that we have perfect control over our program
and therefore can observe everything.
But what happens if this information is not available?
If all we know is that the failure occurred but we have no history,
or means to observe what was going on?
This is where the Sherlock Holmes method of debugging comes into play.
For we must, like Sherlock Holmes, think backwards from our observations
to find out what has really happened.
In debugging, we start with the failure and think backwards
what could be the possible cause such that we can finally discover the reason.